the current counter-offensive is not
Ukraine's first and hopes are pinned on
the success of the last that took place
here in the Northeast when Russian
forces were driven out of the kharkiv
region Last Summer
months later and little has been rebuilt
yet some people are returning they feel
they have no choice
some places are being rebuilt some not
at all
why did we have to do this for ourselves
we were the first ones to be hit
Irina is a doctor who once kept her
large family close but now most are
displaced by the war she'll share her
one-bedroom apartment with one of her
sons and two grandchildren and no
running water
in Village after Village across a swathe
of territory half the size of Belgium
people are slowly coming back often
within artillery range of the Russian
lines
safety is relative here in
uses weapons that include Heavy
Artillery air attacks mortars the most
dangerous thing is that you never know
where they will hit next
and the job of demining making Fields
safe for agriculture and the rubble of
homes safe from unexploded Ordnance will
likely go on for years when its
occupants fled this orphanage was used
by Russian soldiers as a command post
remaining largely undamaged but the war
has left its mark
s
so hard for the kids now you can you
could see our situation there are still
a lot of places mined so they can't run
around free or go to the park or hang
out the girls used to play sports the
boys played football and basketball but
now they can't in many parts of kharkiv
and this region that borders Russia just
40 kilometers north of here life is
returning and sometimes in spite of
terrible destruction that they just
aren't the means yet to begin to rebuild
it's not life as it was far from it but
what they've lost in innocence they've
gained in Hope knowing that here at
least the Russian army was beaten Jonah
Hall Al Jazeera harkive